Speaker 1: As if we needed any more confirmation
that Madison Cawthorn being kicked out of
the House of Representatives after just one
term is a very, very good thing.
I'm going to present to you today exhibit
number 150 of why Cawthorn using his final
speaking opportunity on the floor of the House
to rail against and I quote here, soft metrosexuals.
Take a look at this clip.
This is a guy who seems obsessed with gender
stuff and even cultural issues that aren't
big issues.
Now, I think it's been 12 years since I heard
the term metrosexual, because here is Madison
Cawthorn delivering this final principled
and defiant speech on the floor of the House
of Representatives.
Speaker 2: Our young men are taught that weakness
is strength, that delicacy is desirable, and
that being a soft metrosexual is more valuable
than training the mind, body and soul.
Social media has weakened us, stifling our
men of their will to fight, to rise in a noble
manner, square their jaws in charge once more
to the breach of life to defend what they
love.
So on this precipice of disaster, I. Ask the
young men of this nation a question Will you
sit behind a screen while the story tales
of your forefathers become myth, or you stand
resolute against the dying light of America's
golden age?
We reclaim your masculinity.
Will you become a man to be feared, to be
respected, to be looked up to?
Or you let this nation's next generation be
its final generation?
Speaker 1: That line about Will you become
a man to be feared?
You know.
Call me crazy, but I respect people who garner
respect, not who make others afraid.
And in fact, often those who make others afraid
are quite cowardly people when it really comes
down to it.
And this is really, you know, it's easy to
say, oh, it's Madison Cawthorn with another
one of his wacky rants on his way out.
Don't let the door hit you as you as you exit
sort of thing.
But he brings up an idea or a concept that
is becoming increasingly common among the
right, which is that fear is they just love
fear in every sense.
They they see those who are feared as powerful
and to be respected.
They use fear based politics and fear mongering
to get people to vote for them.
Oh, the you've got to be afraid of the violent
immigrants that are coming in and you've got
to be afraid of the crazy communists that
have taken over Congress.
And of course, none of these things are true.
Fear is a big part of their politics.
And Madison Cawthorn just explaining an additional
way in which that's the case.
Now, as far as the metrosexual stuff, I don't
know that I've heard anyone complain about
metrosexual since 2008.
Like, yeah, very, very, very early in 2008,
I would even say.
And for people who maybe don't remember or
never knew what that term meant, metrosexual
referred to a young, often urban heterosexual
male.
Often with left leaning political views.
Who's interested in fashion and has what might
be considered a refined sense of taste?
And it was a way of criticizing heterosexuals
who you can't just say, Oh, they're gay by
saying this is a brand of heterosexuality
that is sort of less manly and less masculine.
Again, I haven't heard metrosexual as a term
used in a very, very long time, but we clearly
know what is on Madison Catherine's mind.